I have a fitting for my music video
that's it I was so hungover I played a
show last night
I played a show for Jordan last night
which is a and Travis Scott and I got
[ __ ] I got [ __ ] that we had a dance
we had a stripper pole on stage and I
danced she was next level yeah uh-huh
this [ __ ] was next-level [ __ ] yeah and
she was next level yeah I wish I had
some snow I could shovel in my outfit hi
my freestyles don't impress him he had
the same expression on his face yeah
expressive a little bit yeah yeah are
you smiling no I like that number work
for it though cuz sometimes I have
expression in my mind I'm thinking this
is outstanding
so what were you when you heard race
forever black Tweedles for the first
time damn I was at their listening party
yeah and they they went crazy yeah they
were like yo this next one y'all don't
know what yeah but y'all [ __ ] weed and
they all went so crazy so we got on the
couches and started jumping up and down
it was at a conference the party was a
party party it was the actual listening
party like they had the free drinks it
was beets - beets wow that's a great
question cuz I had a great answer I look
so popular with the answer yeah well
first time I heard it oh it was
exclusive and slimmed Ricky what's his
name Jimmy Jimmy and so Jimmy and
Jimmy
wait what's right arrest me brothers me
that's you may await you [ __ ] with the
terror men men the terrible I don't know
the rest of the lyrics I want to make
music I'm a musician that was a lot of
fun it was a crazy there's a crazy tour
now it's crazy I know something I feel
like I don't want to put his okay Sarah
Goethe threw up on the bed in a hotel
and you know a bunch of girls tours so
we we jump up on the bed and like hit
each other with pillows and he was drunk
and in the middle of it that was like
the last night of the towards old man
face was motion I came in gave him a
Dramamine Jam
[Music]
so I don't vomit all over wanna vomit
relax
motion sickness 1779
that'll make it home Joseph stop it I
[Music]
was looking at some YouTube stuff and
found a few videos of you interviewing
folks that you interviewed little Kim
yeah were you doing music at the same
time did you start off just doing some
journalist oh you know what let me tell
you about this so near Luke Kim was
hanging down she is the girl my
interview was about cuz I have a podcast
called good as hell it's on Spotify
[ __ ] imma tell you old [ __ ] imma trade
by my [ __ ] podcast out now and
kailani was this week oh we also did
and guess what Trina is next week this
is so polite no I was not briefed on
this I don't know what we're doing but I
love it
okay first two but I also want to tell
the story you'll see male rappers and
the things that they did things from the
past and things from the future
I got a bag goes I got a bag of the
shake and that's good for me and now I
just had my back to Hannibal breathe the
raid I was drinking a smoothie have to
read Kiwis in it and she was real for me
then I added some other healthy [ __ ]
they're not the cocaine cancel it out
drink a Naked Juice to drink some
Hennessy right behind it
where's my mom I can't find it hitting
on the buzzers when I'm trying to Rapid
City's get you off beep what I'm trying
to snap all right when I get a pedicure
I doubled my tip because they could get
my feet and they be like oh [ __ ]
and as they sawed off my feet and they
get the scrubbing [ __ ] kind of tickle
[Music]
all right with a little fish no it's not
like that's a that's like an animal's
rights issue like they eaten the day
just get off your feet like oh yeah
that's my bra it's illegal it's illegal
but but they're getting fit they're like
you know their food of choice well I
mean are they putting special seasonings
on edit day like are they just see how
they just eaten the feet
they just eat the fish do how everyone
has tastebuds fish fiash no way to know
what that should taste like I love this
sound
it's like a slide whistle
I feel like Pharrell Williams and any Rd
what's have you go I might be like
change and then I keep the bass football
is there are dog barking yo sodas be
dull that's an ego song do we have to
pay me goes woo I don't want to pay me
goes I don't want to pay a baby yes
you'll be pretty expensive I can't pay
you legals
[Music]
but I will barter with you offer you
ad lib so you can mix them up behind the
tracks here's my ad-lib audition in
between when you spit what do you say
there's a different hat let me shout out
your crew who's my crew they ran North
Atlanta all right this is this cause for
the bear me
[Applause]
[Music]
I love music because we don't really
know what it is I'm throwing my hand in
the air and it's just made my heart is
racing
it's a beautiful machine yeah keeping up
with the car - - - keeping up my heart -
- keep the nut the car - - - I'm gonna
need you you'll be keeping up my car -
dad's dick keep it real quick hot dance
dance
keeping up with Chris Jeanie
[Music]
I'm keeping up window Hey
[Music]
[ __ ] I hate that sound was that like a
diving board
[Music]
I see come on target Massey Massey okay
yeah I got about 200 necks what I saw me
six different sharks plus more t-shirts
[Music]
keep yourself working so I see I see
[Music]
these beat these bees beetle kind of
short huh the songs got to be sure come
on we could do like a epic 10-minute
song if you want to do that yeah tell me
your whole life story of ten minutes oh
you want to know we're gonna find the
right sound what's good [ __ ]
I love the arpeggiator on this very I'm
Hamilton I mean not Hamilton that was a
bad very arpeggio our pay are in our
pezzi oh yeah it's like a scale when you
hold on a bunch of keys and then they
all just play that's the operator but
arpeggio is like the first the third the
fifth and the octave of a scale okay
yeah it's called the arpeggiator in nerd
terms they have the button there
[Music]
you are on beat I like that what's wrong
[Music]
they're back on the beat like back on
the beat back on the feet life can come
back on the street
with a white girl
[Music]
see you dumb
[Music]
calm beach dance sounds hard dad
[Music]
Jesus mom alright beast mode this
[ __ ] thing so like a sentimental song
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
on the drum pad after he's started to
catch up at each other I'm really we're
all just trying to figure out the
chemistry man you know I like that just
like that we gotta get ahead of I am the
band back together huh gotta get the
band back together let's go baby
[Music]
like you're not shy of instruments a lot
of the gifts we have right over there
like what is this wood buttons water
what are these do what is the stair man
thing and you you know what you went for
it you know I'm a musician oh yeah I'm a
music originally originally from where
Houston are you from Detroit Detroit
originally from Detroit grew up in
Houston and grew up in Houston yeah
weird does that make sense
I'm from Detroit but I grew up in
Houston when do you women when did you
get over to Houston when I was 10 10
right doesn't have time where'd you go
to high school Houston in Houston hey
that's where that's where your bases
they say the formative years yes the
formative years yeah and then
Minneapolis then Minneapolis and
Minneapolis loves you yeah I love
Minneapolis I'm gonna make the same
mistake last time I did an interview an
airline whatever they were like so where
are you from which would you gonna claim
yeah I was on Jesus of Maryland they're
like you claim Houston you claim
Minneapolis or Detroit and I was like
Minneapolis is like oh now I'm about to
make the same damn mistake but I just
want to say like I love Minneapolis I
said Minneapolis is like that [ __ ] des
claims you in public
yeah and the other two cities aren't do
y'all know what that's like
whoa we're gonna take it there this is
that Harry Potter know if there's people
you're I mean [ __ ] all about it let me
find what can you win
[Music]
all right why do you sigh why you all
shy about attune all of a sudden Hanna
will be he be acting funny when you see
me oh you guys had beef no we never had
beef I made it up
I like making up beef with because if
you have beef we should wrap battle it
out right now
you know what no smoke imma change the
goat the goat sounds I love whatever I
say battle people just tighten up like
yeah right what you mean did you battle
it up I I would I mean I don't really I
have bad I battled in strip club many
others mm-hmm what's one hog is downtown
mm-hmm the only black one and we were
outside and his girls like you are apple
you ain't no rap I'm a rapper I'm a
battle you and I was wasted and I
battled or not one ask POS he was there
yeah do you remember any of the lines I
was drunk I was in strip club no I just
remember I won cuz she was like okay
yeah walked up she gave respect she did
yeah I think we might have danced
together for a second and then she
walked up to you that's how women settle
are do you rap battle it out nice little
twerk off you know the world will be a
better place if you just rather it was
ran by women you what that it was ran by
women that's what I meant to say uh-huh
and well
imagine like Hillary Clinton rat
battling with like Donald Trump she
would have won the election
I want effect on my voice because
everything I doing here would be like
yeah which mics and then you can you
could yeah go back and forth on the
sentence right there go back and forth
on the settings just turn that knob and
[Music]
time for the theremin listen on a family
can flip them my drums
go go go
then go you wanna play a new solo go go
go go yeah go go go listen there is so
low fever that the chicken hair with
this this one
ha River this little that was the right
third I like the way to do it are that
sound sound like a dog trying to say
chance the rapper song for you
[Music]
no I like the kid I like the kid I'm not
gonna lie to you but it's just they
don't go with nothing um I'm hungry what
y'all want some chips like it's a meal
oh I don't like that we don't know
copulation [ __ ] what's wrong with the
chips y'all tryin to get rid of him
snacks I don't eat pizza before a shoot
slice cheese and bread is it good
that's great I've never thought outside
he couldn't beat so in California but
that's not bad at all are you from Kabul
oh don't be
what's Kanye's a kid named Chicago hey I
just wanted to make it relevant five-o
was really dig this fits or not cheese
on crackers
hey this yo California what is this [ __ ]
let's cut bread with sauce tops not
balls not really looks good
hot dogs no ketchup just mustard you
bastard that's how we eat it yeah you
gave me ketchup and I'll beat your
[ __ ] face that's how I do it I ain't
mace
I got emotions I got the potion it's
called wine I like to find time hello
Portillo's kill you Italian beef with
the hot and sweet peppers I'm a loose
pepper well that's right that's right
swear
yep yep
I'm from the side to what when I get the
hot dog
I don't even [ __ ] up by the ketchup put
on the catsup [ __ ] that
Chicago style rule [ __ ] I got that much
to say about that food so I gotta move
on some other [ __ ] that I really do how
about my chest I went into this little
boutique that [ __ ] really sucked but I
bought a book and I ain't even like read
about 10 pages to through it to the back
of the place but you put all this [ __ ]
on them one of your plays yo I should
make the read juice I drank a good
amount of weed juice before the podcast
and I underestimated how long it might
last give me that juice give me that
juice camera that motherf ing dribble
eyes drew shimmy that juice coming out
juice give me there we Jimmy give me
that you chose to give me that give me
that we
okay widows widows we just
wait says smoke the Sun reduce dinner
wait wait chicken wings and a weed sauce
to go on top song is really shifting now
[Music]
[Laughter]
can I get another slice slice slice
slice slice look y'all really about to
eat another slice of this damn pizza I
have a shoot tomorrow I can't be eatin
bread of chasing meat after 8 o'clock
it's no I might as well just eat bread
cheese and meat the next day why will
that affect you because you just I'm
wearing this like skin tight latex
bodysuit so I just wanna be lookin
smooth a slice of pizza it's nothing do
nothing you will see that triangle in my
ass buddy real sensitive my music video
I'm for it to be a bad [ __ ] ok what's
the song it's a new song released
unreleased yeah I'll hurt oh well I've
been playing it all to her cuz you know
I'm not the kind of artist my [ __ ] don't
leak mm-hmm don't nobody really leak or
care my music comes out earlier I
disagree you got some diehards I do but
it's different you know there are
artists who like are at risk of I mean
he really being leak
you're not Bruce Springsteen but you
know yeah I'm no Bruno Mars I know that
is anyways okay anyways so is the new
album new - yeah I'm going on tour with
heyn heyn heyn heyn oh man he has three
girls for long hair and they play all
tournaments
yeah it's gonna be so fun they're gonna
be open and then you're supporting I'm
supporting hime we're playing Radio City
Music Hall we sold it out two nights in
a row as dope as [ __ ] when I say we I'm
just trying to piggyback oh my god meet
me I am you got the little fans in there
diehards yeah there's gonna be a little
drop a little drop up I'm gonna be like
what's thought to my fan yeah and you're
gonna win new fans oh yeah that's the
point that's why I love support tours
you just lay back yeah you know put the
cross your fingers put it behind your
head I've been headlining too long yeah
I'm tired you want to get on that you
want to get on the main stage you want
to get in that Radio City world
yeah I'm tropically Madison Square yeah
of course you do so to answer your
[ __ ] question your
[ __ ] question
answer that [ __ ] let me tell you real
quick okay my first show was at the
varsity that was a big [ __ ] deal
I even deserve that [ __ ] yet but I was
playing on a very Shaq field it was 12
here was 2 minute oh my god then we
played the show just girl cry look me in
my eyes she said please move here
[Music]
and it was safe
hey don't kid and I play 4th avenue
bunch of times and I play the sculpture
garden a couple times and I failed
through a stage in the got a couple
bruises I [ __ ] lie
and I play princess house [ __ ] I know
[ __ ] was super tight a woman go home
[Music]
Minneapolis hear me yeah Palace yeah
what's up with this
any more questions [ __ ] that was
hard I don't even expect them to nose to
sound like jaws huh what do I weigh what
do you buy a boat you know I like to buy
in bulk
various nuts like cashews - she told me
that cashews don't go bad you can you
can get a big-ass jar of cashews and it
will last you a very long time
beef jerky - beef jerky good buy bulk
get a big-ass bag of beef jerky are you
a chef
no I just like food you look like a
seven door cuz you [ __ ] cookie
because I got these beats Oh fire what
and a free Stalin I ain't no liar
look at me on the drum machine yeah
that's me
Tony T with a double M way I'm doing
this it's very troubling this is not
good because we got a fresh new rapper
here and she can do it much better it's
also the white coat it makes you kind of
look like a chef right but ago dududu
really beautiful at least you didn't
think at least you didn't think the
Asian stereotypical round to say you'll
look like you might be working in a
computer lab or something people say of
course they don't people so damn dumb
sometimes
don't you hate people people people that
like last night before I went to bed I
woke up inhaler the venue I played last
night so I find the closest 24-hour cbs4
and warning up and I put in the order
for the refill and get there and there's
fibers now and then a lady what are you
doing up so early
hmm because I was dying
[Laughter]
does she know she was giving you the
inhaler she heads I'm sick I feel
terrible right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yep descent affirmative vocal consent
can I touch its it cannot such what do
you do you think that we gonna have 45
another term no oh hell no hell he's not
gonna make it held no yeah we don't have
another Republican though his his
approval ratings just keep sinking so I
don't think that's gonna happen I don't
think it's gonna repeat but it's wishful
thinking this wishful thinking okay I
don't feel I don't think you a minority
in here how do you feel about who did
you vote for
oh he voted for Bernie Sanders
Ronnie Ron Paul you feeling the Bern
know who you vote for her put the camera
in his [ __ ] face not you good
we could just put turning the skillet on
in this [ __ ] turning you all against
each other yeah fight
fight to the death fight to the death
fight to the death to the death to the
death to the duck yes I thought she was
questioning me but she was just typing
me
so we dream to the death to the death I
get what you mean all the way to the
death seems a bit extreme
how about three rounds five minutes each
and if somebody's not bleeding we call
it no I love you I love you you are so
important you are so important to all it
is thank you you know I'm just I've just
I feel like I fill in the drums when I
feel the energy and I try to follow you
guys I want are you you're a musician I
I'm more of a producer I'm more of a
nerd who knows how to work these buttons
oh so you the music person you bring the
music he brings the yeah oh yeah the
nerdy [ __ ] is me the the everything yeah
good it's a good show it's a fun show
yeah what the [ __ ] is going on here the
hell this is a weird episode but it's
weird how does it normally go this is
how I normally goes that's great this is
great we would never know over here do
you guys actually have questions on the
pocket we do you got you guys just like
weirdly knew some things about sure okay
Liz OH
[Music]
[ __ ] what's the question we asked
realism chef freestyling that's annoying
hey wait hard let me get that let me get
this
whoops I ruined it I ruined it
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
yo yo we chillin over here like it's a
hotel lobby besides music what's your
other hobbies oh I like eating food I
like going to school I like going out
what stupid fool
what I meant to say break the rules
yeah I like to go well I'd like to break
the rules I like to do stuff with my
food my Fuli old paper Coolio
sometimes I go to the studio my studio
is an echo park weird place for us to do
but we make art so pop it we outside
[Music]
but [ __ ] live coz there's bees in
that bridge you gotta you gotta you
gotta you got you gotta make mistakes to
be perfect and you're never gonna be
perfect well your life is just all
mistakes you know I was raised by a
sheep parents oh really
perfection oh I could have been adopted
I could have been adopted by some really
this Q&A is gone down you ain't part I'm
not I had a little eyes though that's
not why I asked today I wanted it to be
yeah yeah you cannot take the Tanaka
sword by stealing it you must earn it
you are what's your problem with action
movies what's your beef I just don't
like all of it all that going on you
don't like the fighting the last action
movie I saw was die harder or diet get
dead die harder to die hard is it was
like the big one oh yeah movie sucked oh
yeah
so Bruce Willis right it's in the movie
and he like jumps it's like on a
helicopter no no no this scene is so
ridiculous right tell me if this is the
scene he's like the helicopter he just
somehow gets into a car like flies
through and he's in the car the car
rolls over and then slow motion is
rolling and then he slides out of the
car and walks like normally as like an
explosion happens behind him so you know
like you don't like that is that's so
[ __ ] unrealistic yeah you don't like
that yeah you're one of those people it
pissed me off so much I was like I don't
want I don't want to do this anybody's
the date of God I was like that it's
like there's no way that could happen
Oh like the small but love but fantasy
and I love like action I like you like
Game of Thrones
I don't watch Game of Thrones but Liam
Neeson and all of the taken films I
appreciate hello to Wayans brothers
y'all know him tell him I say hi I will
tell the cute one
yeah which one's the Q 1 Marlon Marlon
Marlon Liz Oh says what's up is that
happening is does he watch this wait he
watches us
Marlon got a quote was that Marlon is
Shawn that had the crazy pre-show ritual
was a Shawn or Marlon pre-show for the
show yeah I like Martin was it Hannibal
he was just really uh he was he was
serious about it
Oh Marlon probably did that as a warm-up
you gotta get that voice going I'm
Trevor Noah Trevor Noah's [ __ ] mic
check this guy why he just named and
already sexy black man I was the only
sexy black man I have crazy warm-ups to
I mean it's a tool-assisted to the only
two started to it as memorable to me
damn they have to be sexy black men what
can I do universe I'll just be guy black
I walk out me I go yep yep we got it
because uh thanks y'all see how the show
well you have a rubbery voice you don't
it's very elastic you don't have to and
you also stay in one tone yeah yeah I
keep it blank face for about 20 minutes
in blank voice and not exhausted yeah I
have a very expressive face and voice
and it is exhausting uh I've never
really thought about it like that yeah
shopping more like this like Daria
thought he'll do fine watches ourselves
oh yeah
in person though no I have I see you see
me live I saw you at some tea with with
the moon kavanah was opening for you
guys that was great yeah the girls
dancing you had the whole [ __ ]
shebang bang
you thought it shows great oh my god
great
those girls are they always the same
girls my PJ they were getting it they
always get it yeah it was a good it was
very pleasing to the eye
well thank you it's good al our shows
are poppin you gotta cook you gotta make
it someone will come to us so we don't
play we gonna play with hime yeah we did
we kind of did a show together at the
South by remember at the Brandon's party
you remember yeah oh yeah we did a show
that uh cuz we will DJ in y'all went on
afterwards he had a little team parties
let's eat you was that team party yeah
what I don't remember that oh yeah I
remember oh you know the bouncer was
screaming at my DJ well no my DJ was
screaming at the bouncer and it was
trying to like kick her out and that was
that's what happened I don't even worry
that's the only thing I remember about
that and then she like kicked a wall
she's like five two oh did it did the
wall take any damage the wall was like
it's fine it's fine
no hard feelings at the wall
[Music]
it's cool
[Music]
skittles on the to see what happens yeah
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
I was at Tokyo they served me Suzie
cereal
believe it but I tried it out they gave
me half up and then I had cornflakes and
some goddamn spicy to the world's in my
[ __ ] mouth that's it then mix well
spit it out the bathroom then I flipped
the couch and the lounge part of this
restaurant went back behind the counter
grabbed some other stuff
sashimi rolls
[Music]
[Music]
I dropped that on purpose just to make
you mad I thought about it I should have
been think about it the betta pass
damn dog Oh finally tell us a joke yeah
give me a one-liner okay all right so
I'm walking down all right come on down
ha ha so well go down Skid Row ha and
they rose to it for the walking down huh
Skid Row and tourists comes up to me
says where's you know what a local
dispensary is and I said Tim no I don't
I don't know where it is I can't I can't
help you I'm not from you I don't really
know my way around well rimshot you
remind me back in the day when I used to
stand on the corner with the bag yay all
right bye yay I mean all that easy
merchandise I will sell the shirts out
on the street Hollywood and Highland
sell your seat I said your seat is
sometimes easy this supposed to cost
$500 but you can get him 450 for me and
I sell you a bootleg DVD faceoff with
bad boys - that's a double feature
[Music]
Nicholas Cage was my acting teacher I
used to say when you can look in the
camera over at spit out your mouth have
a lot of energy do that take about 15
times and then do it again look into the
camera even Las Vegas was that nominated
[Music]
look into the camera like Will Smith
with one of those freshness look into
the camera like Will Smith one of those
fresh look into the camera like Will
Smith yeah look is it a camera like Will
Smith did one of those Fresh Prince
episodes I wish I was a fresh prince
when they would have really really lean
into the bit yeah Nicholas Cage
how you feel about Nicholas Cage I love
Nicholas key you know he's a Coppola
yeah I know yeah I know that I'm like oh
they always change their name Sophia you
know misogyny runs rampant in the
directorial world yeah everything I'm
like y'all got chips you know that
slaves used to make [ __ ] yeah I know I
knew I was a couple oh I like can you do
a Nicholas Cage impression somebody stop
me can you do you know like what's up
famous lives or fast types of French my
life what's that's that's not even sound
like anybody I don't know I'm gonna have
take his face off
that's good as a face-off this I am a
convict and I am on this airplane and
we're gonna escape was he ever not hype
mm-hmm yeah he's intense he's an intense
fella I only I only remember like the
goofy babbling Nicholas Cage
like the one where he played a twin and
in a he died that's faceoff right no no
he plays he's in the movie twice it's
called like adaptation oh that's a great
movie no you're right that is a great
movie but it was also written by Charlie
Kaufman so anybody could write yeah that
was Charlie Kaufman
oh I'm the guy Andy Kaufman oh I was
like he did hi they run a movie 20 years
later but that would have been Lynn Andy
Kaufman has some ancient scripts
somewhere that he had locked away and
then somebody unearthed with this movie
I ever seen Being John Malkovich oh
that's a good movie yes Charlie Kaufman
can you do a John Malkovich impression I
can Malkovich Malkovich I think it's
hard to tell what you sing it you know I
guess you can't do like an impression of
an actor like singing that's weird
wait do one I'm John Malkovich man we
have the worst impression was your girl
let me hear yours I don't have any well
you gotta come up with something we
tried let's try we gotta take shots
shots some John my world is insane and
what movie does this come from I will
break you Creed Mortal Kombat actually
you're very close Rocky
timber 3 I'm actually I must break you
rocky 4 well you should have said must I
[ __ ] up I'm sorry damn I'm gonna edit
that out I have to see I have a scene
rocky floor what what yeah we won the
Cold War because of that movie I've
never seen Rockies I've never even seen
Creed even though Michael B Jordan II
what this interview is over
oh my god I don't get mad people haven't
seen stuff okay eight we cool what about
Angry Birds what about the air beef we
squashed the beef how many movies you
been in six shot rumble in the Bronx all
right hey drunken master wait what I was
like you got me on drunken mess I was in
front right really yeah haha my high
school band I was in marching band and
we got chosen to be the high school band
in Friday Night Lights the opposing one
the cool one and then they used me in a
trailer but it's like really quick and
it's like a bunch of us and I'm just
waving my flute back and forth really
fast I think they sped it up did you get
that roll it was my whole high school
band they just chose us so we made
Rovers and I thought Billy Bob Thornton
yeah day we also got chosen to be in a
Super Bowl day years a year to Janet
Jackson year yeah very traumatizing well
I'd be so excited and be like yeah hey
we're watching the Super Bowl and I was
like I love you Justin he's like I love
you and we were like well watched him
and Janet and they're like after the
whole thing happened they were like
we're never coming to Houston again
y'all been banned like they were so evil
so I saw the whole - anything happens I
I saw the rehearsal for the titty thing
well so it was planned wait what so that
[ __ ] was not a mistake
listen I'm not I don't want anything to
get out of control here coach me on
don't wanna leak no secrets listen Janet
Jackson is a national treasure and I
love her I think everybody already knew
that
okay I think everybody already I will
say this wardrobe malfunction that
phrase was invented by that moment so
let's just keep it all the way 100 it
was invented because of that moment it
did not exist before that moment so
let's just say somehow chittery went
down and they they oh my god yeah an
apology and you know what ya said it she
had a patient she had a pasty on her
nipple come on come on come on if you go
show that titty no this ain't even about
Janet I think that she was incredible
and I think the in the artistic
integrity behind that moment was valid I
think the reaction of everyone else
mmm was a little weird cuz if that
happened now in 2018 and do a leaper
show tulo titty during a it wouldn't it
what do you think but you know I think
that's just society's progression as a
people yeah you know in our our
relationship with sexuality and nudity
especially on women and especially brown
women is changing and evolving and
hopefully that's 20 years from now it's
a beautiful thing we can just show full
titties at the Super Bowl titties are
beautiful titties are beautiful
hey let's go tap tap it to the next one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful sign I call the fire
department
it's hot somebody call the fire hottie
here don't bring the heat if you if you
in the kitchen if you can tell but he'd
get your ass up the casino wait let me
see I think I got a Nicolas Cage
impression let's hear it I think you're
hot thank you that's good thank you you
sounds like that right it's way better
than my horse weaker heart oh thank you
I just needed to prove myself I'm a
perfectionist I'm kind of hard on myself
so when you challenged me I've been
thinking for the last ten minutes I'm
gonna make a comeback
I'll do your John Malkovich periwinkle
blue Patti that's good - periwinkle blue
you're a natural
thank you I said I want it Paris you're
like a female Jay Ferrel I'm like Jay
I'm like I don't gotta be why I gotta be
female you're a Jay Pharoah I'm
schooling these [ __ ] and gender
equality yeah one of these days we gonna
get the same amount we not gonna get the
minimum wage but I'm just saying I'm not
gonna be a war with the Maine cuz I
might have to go super saiyan and blow
the [ __ ] I put the [ __ ] brain but
your [ __ ] brains out
[Music]
you gonna pass the [ __ ] plant oh I
wasn't gonna do it but so way I might
have to smoke a little weed
I might hex blow a little tree with
Hannibal barista ah you bet your coffee
in the coffee store the coffee shop yeah
[ __ ] is weird
well I don't understand here how do I
get this [ __ ] milk out of almond you
squeeze the milk out of almond you get
it real lubricated make it watch some
porno check it off real quick let it's
worth in the club almond milk that's how
you get it that seems like a weird
process to get almond milk if they do
that [ __ ] at the stores I go to they do
it behind the counter and real quick cuz
that's his thing pretty ain't insane and
a little obscene these people saw that
process they be like you know what I'll
go back to the cow milk position looks
kind of gross can you take that process
back into the back so you know around
the buzz of folks with a children they
like yo mami was that she like turn away
she covers the child's eyes which out
fights to mom and walks back and looks
and like it's almond dick how you think
they kick cow's milk dog okay
Old MacDonald had a farm he had a cow
turned her on cutters got real swollen
[ __ ] then he went down and massaged the
cow click and then he squeezed on the
other other is squirted white milk and
he come
[Music]
okay the whole industry is [ __ ] sick
the industry sick but if you milk a cow
take some of the milk and spill some
into the ground
does it grow another cow like a hot bar
that bar would take this really far and
cow's milk could make another cow I'd be
crazy I'm a one puff is enough kind of
[ __ ] if I smoke anymore I'm gonna be we
burnt up the camera wow I mean how long
do these things go we go as long as you
feel like kind of go and then it it's
fun and it's fun and it's still fun and
edit counter we realize literally you
just let me know when you want to leave
I just got home yeah so you about to get
weird yeah I looked at my hand and I was
like wow that means we got another hour
left
Wow I have a hand no I was looking my
nails at Burberry listen I get high so
easily this is embarrassing
that's not embarrassing I guess let's
change the sound right oh my god the
volume how was the show in red rocks
with atmosphere a couple years back how
do you know about that okay when was
this show the show was a two years ago
Oh
so those atmosphere still having a
strong following like that yeah yeah yes
yes look what slug-like is he a nice guy
he's really cool yeah I was a big fan
back in the day really big fan really
well I didn't know much about it until I
moved there cuz but the whole city is
like yeah I'm saying yeah yeah and then
they got the and then they got the dome
tree the dome trace and the Rhine Sayers
don't trace underarms and erasers you
know it's crazy man it's really cool to
see
how much a city can life support and
bigger partisan like paint the town
would they've been [ __ ] so dope I can't
really think of any other cities where
the local scene is I mean obviously you
know Atlanta Portland local scene like
that ain't got no hip-hop scene Seattle
where's McLemore from he's from Seattle
Seattle
yeah but Macklemore sucks that's your
opinion you know there's a whole city of
[Laughter]
he just sounds like a PC slug to me it
wasn't a thug you sound like you're not
doing drugs not enough you should be
okay you should be tough but your
[ __ ] shop at thrift stores buy and
Levi's like a [ __ ] spoke a nice guy
hey let's stand up whoa
Macklemore huh make some [ __ ] songs
and stop acting poor yo you got money
no you're not funny shut up Tommy
whoa you know you know not a fan why
can't we can't we all just get along
why always like that so you know am I'm
at Colombo fan I mean I liked his um I
really liked oh man I can't even think
of the song but the song we got the
singer on their stupid doors when he
came out he's more like Makela less know
so me how Sony gotten two votes Natalie
did he did the diss song he did a
mclemore there sorry what a battle come
to my house and then he have follow-up
questions questions like you [ __ ] with
back little boys like damn you mad
come at me bro come it man come at me
bro this is the base this place there we
go
come at me bro come at me bro at me bro
back to back like Drake oh my god I'm
gonna show you my
sitting hey Mack more wait what you
stole grab me from kensic oh you ain't
[ __ ] nice guy I'm sure he's a nice guy
okay I'm sure he's a nice guy but you
know that's like the industry standard
if you don't like someone's music but
you know you shouldn't be talking [ __ ]
they say so how do you feel about solo
so you say she's a nice girl he's a nice
guy that's what you do you gotta talk
about the content of their character
yeah not enough the music content of
their art exactly that's true
Oh happens all the time have you noticed
that oh yeah definitely
now who's interviewing you oh the tables
ever turned when did you notice it
give us the juicy musta - I noticed this
way back when because me and Serengeti
he's the Touareg I used to be as DJ
uh-huh and then you would ask somebody
like so what do you think about
atmosphere and be like oh that slug he's
a nice guy you know I was fearful like
atmosphere I like slug but I'm just
saying they would be I'm sorry - I'm not
calling him odd I'm just saying I know I
come on every day struggle that's the
industry pardon
my bad that's an industry term I feel
like that's a nice he's a nice guy she's
a nice girl but that's it that's it well
you know what we're all nice people so
no not everybody
hey McLemore you should be called Mack
I love you I'm sorry okay I don't know
what would jump would hopped into you
that's not like his music oh okay what
music do you like here we already talked
about
I like Bjork a lot there we go well
clearly this is like a [ __ ] present
yes I can I got I got I got a pure
compression Eisen I have to go to the
market right now let me hear your Bjork
impressive come on we're interviewing
you Jonathan song yeah should be like
Chewbacca I love it you did that in the
middle of the tracks of you Wow
yeah a lot of passion I love do you feel
that I Love New York oh my gosh oh gosh
oh yes let's make a Bjork song what that
there me bjorg if you're out there and
you listen to the handsome ramble I just
wanna let you know
Shawna's got nothin but love for you
shrim life damn it we broke the theremin
boy we broke the camera wrote the
theremin nothing but chips started a
beef squashed a beef squashed equal
[Music]
squash
I still got beef no Meah Hannibal's beef
that I had before I came on a podcast I
used this promo for the Thurman on
Macklemore to Dereham is gone whose
shows and live concerts kind of
influenced Charles to make it a kind of
a big high energy production whose souls
are you saying oh inspires my I've seen
Beyonce like [ __ ] ten times how many
times you seen Beyonce think says once I
saw a show at the Rose Bowl when it was
the one that saw her and jay-z did they
hit like when drunken love started how's
this show yeah
Oh going solid show well yeah I was
talking to a girl she was such a Beyonce
fan she was saying if if it's a if it's
a woman's between 21 and 35 and she own
like Beyonce I don't trust her yes you
say a black woman if it's a black woman
between 21 30 some you know like Beyonce
that I can trust you something like
yourself I know that was serious I feel
the same way if someone says my favorite
rapper is McLemore oh my god
just sayin
Oh am I allowed to have opinions no you
are you I'm just being real man you know
I really I'm speaking the truth I know a
lot of people are thinking this who know
what do you think of this - more like
McAvoy music but nothing thank God was
there anybody who initially embraced you
and helped you out a lot in the
Minneapolis scene the first artists I
mean I think it was doomed tree don't
read my back oh yeah the first time I
performed what a second time I got to
perform onstage at First Avenue it was
for Mike mclintock's party I love that
guy together he put me on track with him
yo yo yo shout out paper tiger shut up
and
[Music]
yeah don't beat right there yeah yeah do
a YouTube tutorial on some Beatles [ __ ]
like Eleanor Rigby wait Karma Party do
features like little Wayne a few years
ago when he was on everybody [ __ ] the
[ __ ] was insane but man hey Flo still is
pretty good and Bret got the most
pussy-eating raps of any rapper he talks
about that [ __ ] is that his favorite
snack
[Music]
lo Wang got at least tip [ __ ] tracks
tracks yeah yo go into the shoe store
look at the wacky suit try it on
ask the clerk how we think this [ __ ]
look if he lied and say it [ __ ] looks
good
I say why she noticed [ __ ] his barbers I
was just trying to see if you would be
honest but I see you just trying to
Saudi city shoes for feet so you let me
body city soon make a fluorescent green
and the city soles on the city suit no
although the shoes look good on the
surface but when you walk a few blocks
they fall apart like me at a party when
I'm nervous
[Music]
dan that beat was so [ __ ] hard
Thank You Liz oh that means [ __ ] that
means a lot coming from you lose that
was special thank you yeah yeah and
social anxiety in public I should go
hard together yeah I wish I'm regretting
not having a slice of the pizza it's
okay
Pizza regrets I looked at the phone and
said 45 minutes of beer here I feel
smoke alone with the paper that was used
to role plays back watch a few YouTube
videos Sims go and I wake up to a few
missed calls they said we had to peace
Peter but you to come to the door and we
had to meet you so your pieces is gone
the driver Twilight wanna take it home
with his family
eat my [ __ ] and I flip the book and I
flip the bill I can't beat that [ __ ]
damn I gotta pee so where's the trust
it's pee so don't [ __ ] with us I loved
it up get paid and got a free pizza but
if I see you in the street say you look
like the [ __ ] there have our
peace so then it's gonna be peace unless
you go over there and buy me some new
pieces to replace I took you in the face
in front of
oldest member your family yo you gonna
give your grandma that's trauma
it was my piece so you could have left
on the porch run off piece of regret I
need you to send me my check 35 years
old just join the gang and got a
skateboard at the same time yo yo
i skateboard and kickflip outside of
this is fine this is fun
that was a great time I had a great time
thank you I can do this I can do this
all night yeah wait thank you for having
me thank you
what's the name of your podcast again
good as hell good as hell so that's the
song that I wrote yeah it's called good
as hell well cross-pollination yeah hey
yo Liz oh definitely good uses SEO
search engine optimization smart move
make it easy for people cuz people V all
split up in the mind then lick get your
[ __ ] and then get distracted look at
some ugly [ __ ] at the same time I got 80
feet got 30 times leopard on my computer
see seven of them are the same thing
what
it's going on in my yeah on Saturday
[Music]
[Music]
Tony let's go thank you for doing our
show Thank You Liz oh thanks guys thanks
for having me
check out Rizal was your website my
website follow me on IG Liz I'll be
[Music]
[Music]
hi girls
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]